- Neon was hugely popular in
the ‘30s, ‘40s, the early ‘50s.
With the advent of LED signs,
a lot of the small neon shops folded.
It's important to me to keep neon alive
because I feel like there's so much
more that can be done with it.
I'm Kirk Tunningley, and I'm a neon artist
and a neon tube bender.
I started doing neon, making
three dimensional sculptures
while I was in college, and now I've been
working with neon for 38 years.
In the Austin area, I'll probably have
75 or a 100 neon signs and I've probably
made 500 or 600 signs in my career.
Different signs take
different amounts of time.
There are more elaborate signs where
the glasswork could take 25 or 40 hours.
To make a neon light, is a really simple process.
There's two torches, one
is used to make curves
and the other one, makes sharper angles.
Each bend is heated up and brought
to the pattern and formed and then
marked where your next bend is.
When the glass is heated up, you cork off
one end of the glass tube
and then the other end,
I have a rubber hose and as you bend it,
you blow into the glass to keep
the inside of the tube uniform.
It's a back and forth process
from torch to pattern.
Something I really love about neon lights,
it is the wild factor.
If you put up a display
even a simple display,
it excites people.
There's nothing that looks
better than neon lights at night.
I think it's important that people
keep up the tradition of bending glass.